[Music]
sean is on the line in los angeles sean
welcome to the ramsay show
hi uh thanks for having me absolutely
i
just bought a my wife and i just got
married did for um our uh honeymoon and
all that stuff everything is good you
just bought in her car cash um thank you
very much um so we just bought her car
cash um and then we ended up out of
vehicle
so we have about like maybe like 11 000
saved after everything um and then uh
i'm gonna get six thousand back from
from the other one so
i'm wondering uh do we
go like you know do i kind of try to
spend it all on something and try to get
something a little more reliable or do i
nickel and dime at like five thousand
and throw the rest of it um the only
that we have is a student loan so
kind of um trying to tackle that too so
i'm not really sure what we should do
yeah well i mean i don't like the word
only debt yeah it's the only debt i have
how much is this debt this student loan
oh it's pretty steep it's like 50 57 000
but we're good enough good earners and
you know we haven't we had a map out of
just something unfortunate happened you
know you know what i mean yeah how
urgent is this car purchase
um
it has to be done yeah i mean uh i mean
yeah i mean we both commute for work so
we got to do it and you have one car
right now
one car yeah okay so you need another
car for the job and you have 11 000
saved in cash is that all of your
savings everything liquid cash you have
right now
yeah it was all we we had kind of um i
had planned on just throwing that
straight at the debt and then and then
this came up so now but we do have i'll
get six thousand back from from
everything else
what's everything else
uh my insurance it'll be though you know
okay so they'll write you a check for
six grand you're saying
yeah okay all right that helps we got
all the details down rachel yeah i mean
sean if i was in your boat because of
the student loan obviously you guys need
a car i mean that is we talk about your
four walls transportation is one of
those so i'm not against obviously you
getting a car uh but no i would not
spend all of this on the car because you
can still get a reliable
used car i mean you can
i mean it's amazing honestly four five
six thousand dollars what that will get
you no it's not gonna be a beautiful car
it's gonna be an older one but you go
get you know a honda civic or a toyota
camry like there are there are cars out
there that their
reputation is to be reliable and again
it may not be the thing you want to
drive for the rest of your life which is
fine but going ahead and getting a car
um as inexpensive as possible so again
i'm talking four five six thousand
dollars and then keeping a thousand for
your emergency fund and then in the rest
of this debt so i really would
concentrate on that and the great thing
about
four five six thousand dollar cars is
they really don't go down in value very
quickly so yeah by the time you guys are
out of debt you know in in three more
years you guys can upgrade to an awesome
car and that time is going to fly so
quick so um i would put as much money
towards the student loan shawn as
possible and sorry i'll add this to sean
you know you and your wife hello you
guys have been married what just i mean
really recent you said
oh yeah october yeah they're just coming
october okay
so honestly this is kind of a fun
fun may not be the right word george i
love the word fun so everything feels
fun to me this could be a really
unifying goal for you and your new wife
to to experience something together as a
newlywed couple in any couples but
especially when you're newlyweds to have
something that you guys are sacrificing
and working towards together
um there's something really unifying
about that that you get to experience
early on in marriage so i would almost
look at it like that but hey you know it
sucks that we have all this student loan
debt but man if we attack this together
there is this um
this this bridge between you two that
gets built in such a quicker way when
you have a unified goal yeah and sean
i'll tell you i drive a 2009 honda civic
with body damage so it's exactly what
rachel's saying and i paid six thousand
dollars for it back in 2017.
still drives perfectly today and yeah we
have the money to get a new car but i'm
like that's fine and i kind of like that
it has some body damage you get a little
ding on it you don't care so let this be
a memory that you guys look back on and
let it fuel you to go gosh i hate this
car i wish we had a nicer car let's pay
off this debt asap so that we can get
that nicer car but what happens is
people get a nicer car and they get
comfortable with their student loans
sitting here like a pet and they never
pay them off and so i want you to get
intense
what was that we're hardcore on it we
decided we had already planned on it
it's already i had map out like the next
six months to take care of it we just uh
it's just something came up and i'm like
i don't know if we should you know
totally
this thing is definitely gone in six
months or less and guess what you can
then sell that car for probably about
what you paid if the market is what it
is and you can upgrade uh before the
year is over before 2022 ends
awesome thank you for helping us
absolutely thanks so much for the call
cars are so interesting because there's
like this level of
like a standard of living a level of
luxury this thing that cars have become
it represents something
like you know dave's opener of the show
is this you know the bmw is now the
status symbol of choice and it is i'm
like and what i don't i just laugh at
myself sometimes because i can be that i
want a tesla that's my i'm not a car
person but whenever i see a tesla i'm
like man i want a tesla so bad
and like a car gets you from point a to
point b yeah see what i'm saying like
like if you go to like this you zoom out
the utility of it if you just look at
the utility of it and then like you said
too the nicer the car
a little bit more the more stressed you
are
the more you're thinking oh gosh i got
to keep it clean if something happens
right it becomes this this uh it fills
your emotional tank where it's like oh
it doesn't need to right because it's
just stuff so there's cars are just f
they're fascinating and there's a big
spectrum especially with guys i mean
guys calling into the show yeah it's
always they want the nice car and they
want to impress the buddies and they got
to have this the premium features
yeah so i would be here i wish we could
like take a poll like instagram on the
radio but we can't but i'm like okay for
like the the longing for a new car
especially for a guy
is it do you think george more of the
perception of what it brings
or is it that you just like nice things
and you like to get in to a car and it
smells good it's all new technology like
it's fun
i wonder what percentage it is for most
people out there i think that's a bit of
both but i think if you're an im legend
scenario and you're the only person in
the world left i don't think you're that
worried about what other people think
about your truck so true i think part of
it is you want to go with your buddies
and go hey dude check out check out
these rooms i just got if i just got the
list george if i ever get a tesla i'm
gonna i'm gonna say george i'm taking
him i will be one of those people that
tells you
i love it